welcome to Hannity tonight a critical
multi trillion-dollar stimulus package
is stalled in the US Senate we have no
idea when a vote will take place there
or in the house either
you know in a time of great urgency for
the entire country we have seen let's
start with the best in people look at
all of these businesses take a look at
the screen all of them on your screen
have stepped up in huge massive
incredible heroic ways to help their
fellow Americans producing ventilators
and mask the medical equipment that is
needed for the best doctors the best
nurses the best medical professionals in
the entire world that are on the front
lines helping Americans that are sick
putting themselves in harm's way we
cannot thank them enough for their
service and their courage these
companies have all stepped up this
president and his task force they are
making literally life-saving choices now
rewriting the books with that will
forever transform how we deal with
future pandemics travel bans quarantine
public-private partnerships drive
through testing soon we will have home
testing telemedicine that is that all
this is the future off-label use and
elimination of draconian rules by the
FDA for compassionate use the right to
try why not
vaccine trials in record time make no
mistake you're watching history unfold
this is transformational lives will be
saved and lives are changing but in the
midst of tragedy and triumph and amazing
achievements you know look at the travel
ban alone let's start there
saved thousands and thousands of
Americans from contracting the virus
bought us valuable time and saved
incalculable lives this is America at
its finest all of these things to
protect and save lives of the American
people
President of the United States let me
just say he is now been waiting for a
week for a bill what we have been
watching last week at all this week in
the Washington swamp that is America at
its worst in DC unfortunately during
tough times we do see people at their
worst you see people at a price gouging
for needed supplies medical supplies
maths even then you see the [ __ ]
and people fighting in the rows over
toilet paper it's insane and thankfully
that is not the majority of the American
people and the swamp what we've been
seeing is beyond repulsive just as they
have for three long plus years radical
socialist Democrats do-nothing Democrats
they are hurting the country we have
watched now day after day after day
democratic socialists literally
exploiting a national emergency they
have been holding back
what is desperately needed money for
American workers American small
businesses big industries that have been
basically shut down as a result of this
virus why so they can jam down the
throats of you the American people what
is their disaster a socialist agenda and
of course part of the insane green New
Deal they have held desperately needed
relief monies hostage I saw Susan
Collins this week of Maine literally
where is your urgency we've seen this
I've never ever in my life see Mitch
McConnell that angry either American
workers they needed help last week they
need help now small businesses need help
now big businesses wiped out by the
corona virus they need help now so they
can help their employees now they needed
that last week and here we are a week
later still dealing with democratic BS
what's this all about they have been
literally treating this emergency
stimulus plan like a cookie jar and they
are Prowse price gouging you the
American people I warned you this was
coming
they needed to pass a clean coronavirus
relief bill why waste a good crisis
right rahm emanuel to do the things you
know you would never otherwise get done
yeah pelosi torpedoing a bipartisan plan
over what a green new deal and carbon
footprints and a wish list of unrelated
demands tax credits for windmills and
solar panels and new environmental
regulations for the airlines
yeah let's as if they're not suffering
enough let's kick him in the head while
they're down on the ground bleeding
profusely and they've been devastated
then they add protections all we got to
bring in the
illegal immigrant issue we got to give
new powers to union bosses and on and on
as it stands now with this our only some
of the democratic pork has made it into
this bill but a ton of democratic price
gouging remains look at this a hundred
and fifty million dollars to the
National Endowment for the Arts and the
Endowment for the Humanities oh now it's
down they wanted 600 million originally
that's what they were fighting for
that's what the delay has been about
there's also Oh fifty million dollars
for the Institute of Museum and Library
Services okay if we need money to help
their employees that's separate and
apart that's not what this is about
seventy-five million for the Corporation
for Public Broadcasting in other words
75 million for PBS oh and I think NPR's
included I think NPR's ones one of their
stations announced they're not even
going to take the president's daily
taskforce briefings but they're going to
get 75 million bucks and the cherry on
top of the Democratic wishlist 25
million for DC's Kennedy Performing Arts
Center protect the employees if they're
out of work but this money total BS see
what's happening here you're watching
the exploitation by the Democrats
holding Americans in need hostage over
this garbage all in order to get a big
payday for their close friends and Union
buddies now they know Republicans they
have a sense agency they're the adults
in the room they have been saying we
need to get this help to the American
worker and businesses that are in
trouble
and here the Democrats literally taken
advantage of what is an
all-hands-on-deck moment now if you or I
ever did this we might even be arrested
for theft or looting or price gouging
probably locked up and charged with
larceny but not if you're a Democratic
member in the US Congress and guess what
it gets worse the bill is currently
stalled why because of a provision that
would actually pay workers in many
instances more money than they would
otherwise make on their jobs if they go
on unemployment in other words more
money unemployed than if they were
employed as they currently have been now
an idiotic idea every reasonable
American understands this we need to
help our fellow Americans how about we
just
keep them whole whatever you've been
making you're out of work through no
fault of your own we'll continue to make
sure you make that amount of money
because that amount of money should pay
your mortgage your rent your car payment
and anything else your food your
groceries your pharmacy this is not good
for the American economy it's not fair
to the American taxpayers who are all in
America is willing to help out their
fellow Americans make them whole during
this brief period of time those that
deserve the help deserve how period got
bolshevik Bernie Sanders he's
threatening to stop the whole bill if
this language is removed meeting more
delays for those people that have been
waiting and waiting and waiting and
desperately deserve our help so let's be
clear here here's what the Democrats
have been blocking let's see they've
been blocking a relief bill for American
workers so PBS NPR the Kennedy
Performing Arts Center can get a big
payday and Bolshevik Bernie can get as
socialist wish list completed twelve
hundred dollars direct this is this is
important stuff direct payments to
Americans three hundred sixty billion
seven billion for small business loans
five hundred billion for distressed
companies another 150 billion for
hospitals and health care workers
they're all waiting this could have and
should have been passed a week ago and
as we speak the president is ready to
sign the bill immediately he has been
for days
president he doesn't write the bills in
Congress and in fairness to him he's
been a little bit busy trying to save
the lives of the American people and in
all-hands-on-deck health pandemic and
he's done more than any other president
in history to save lives during a
pandemic
nobody's ever responded this way in the
history of this country but make no
mistake this is even a new low for the
swamp in DC in the Democratic Party and
it just reeks of swamp corruption they
should all be ashamed of themselves they
won't be
they'll all be patting themselves on the
back telling them each other how great
they are they're not what these radical
socialists are doing is beyond the pale
frankly tonight
what you've been watching and we're
still watching as a national disgrace
it's unforgivable and if you're sitting
home tonight Laura
about how you gonna pay your rent your
mortgage put food on the table pay your
car loan off just know the Democratic
Party cares more about NPR PBS the
National Endowment for the Arts and they
care much more about that than any of
you otherwise you would have had your
money by now now this bill will pass I
guess ultimately the Republicans
basically have a gun at their heads
they're trying to get the money to
workers but to get it they got to give
all this garbage to the Democrats so
American workers and small business
large businesses can get the aid we have
been desperately wanting to give to them
mark my words
mark my words tonight this precedent we
are setting well we will pay a huge
price down the line